bonsoir
et voici maintenant notre émission
dramatique du samedi soir si vous voulez
mademoiselle je voudrais m'adresser aux
speakerine carrière beaucoup
d'améliorations apportées
si vous voulez recommencer montre qui
vous allez ma lancée par exemple un
match de boxe nous allons voir c'est
pour que ça bouge fort du mouvement la
gaieté alesi et voici maintenant un
match de pas attendez monter un petit
piège avons des cas c'est qu'est ce
qu'on devait faire prise au dépourvu en
tristesse que je fais ce que l'on me
alors c'est très simple je sens comme
d'habitude
oui mon petit carton est balancé plus à
mon petit ce qu'il faut faire je vais
vous dire c'est le a lancé gaiement un
peu de musique ça fait passer le temps
musique s'il vous plaît nous allons vous
celui
très bien maintenant essayer une
émission politique alors c'est très
simple et voici maintenant controverse
ou deux personnalités politiques
importantes vont se confronter aux mon
petit ça c'est d'une tristesse des
gitans pas de guerre en soi ainsi vous
l'annoncer comme ça c'est s'ils disent
non vous annoncez et envoyé générique de
notre émission controverse il vous plait
tsoin tsoin j'ai la gorge qui très moche
j'ai la droite
maladroits les centristes bientôt de
radical qui va mal je crois que ça va
faire des étincelles
je vois que ça va bouger c'est à vous
engager
ouais et voici maintenant notre émission
dramatique du samu il arrive pas pressée
par la tête parce que c'est pas mal et
toute façon c'est plus grave
mais non alors je vais m'en occuper moi
même comme je fais tout ici et voici
maintenant notre émission dramatique du
samedi soir
kaka vtz qu'elle va chercher
oui mais ça c'est un style nouveau toute
chose pour voir